what uh
was it like meeting and working with
pablo escobar
the leader of the medellin cartel he was
just uh
just seemed like a gentleman when i met
him just like you and i sitting here
shook hands and
i had flown one load for a fella and
it didn't work out well the fellow that
i gave it to got shot and it took a
while to get my money and
they didn't put as many kilos on the
plane as they're supposed to and
so i wasn't gonna work with them anymore
in my contact down there introduced me
to
jorge ochoa and uh we went up
and in regatta we went up and the gate
opened and we was escorted in there must
have been
50 men out in the yards a hissing rail
on an old house
and we was escorted right in and there
was a beautiful woman in there i mean
gore dropped dead beautiful and she made
us a cup of coffee
then was ushered in to see jorge ochoa
and he had 12 telephones on his desk and
all of them was a different color
and he shook hands was very friendly
spoke english
and uh he said that each one of those
telephones were represented in another
city in the united states this is
chicago and this is new york if i ring i
knew who's calling
and so we chatted a while and uh he
asked me what type of airplanes i had
and what experience i had flying across
the u.s border
and i told him he seemed um pleased with
it
and he called the lady in and she went
next door
and came pablo escobar and he introduced
me to pablo escobar and
he asked the same questions again and i
answered him and i said
and i i asked them how much they paid
and they paid five thousand dollars a
kilo
to haul it and uh so how much you put on
the plane he's 300
500 that's one and a half two and a half
million dollars for an eight hour trip
sounded pretty good to me and we're
talking about cocaine
cocaine we're talking about colombia
colombia and cocaine and medellin cartel
and uh jorge ochoa was one of the what
would you say
founding members of the probably the
brains behind the whole thing
the brains and spoke good english yes
and they were nice people
really nice people were you scared not
at all
what's wrong with your mind that you
weren't scared here's some of the most
dangerous men
in this world and you weren't scared
well i knew i was going to do exactly
what i said i was going to do
murray and the children were down there
they went down and they stayed in the
hotel
five-star treated royally on my first
load
and they just did ask security to make
sure that i want a dea agent
so i uh i did the first load and
they would they can say they were
hostages but they really weren't it was
just
insurance so there was some integrity to
the way they operated
completely i mean straight straight up
the money was ironed and bad bad banded
and just right and the numbers were
never once
anything wrong with it what would you
attribute that honesty to
within the their own moral system
and their own set of rules why weren't
people crossing the line
and shaving off the top and and uh
injecting chaos into the system to where
it would be unpredictable and people
would be dishonest and greedy and all
those kinds of things
that's true most people are but there's
certain people at the top of the food
chain that they don't need that
and if they're completely honest then
they don't have to think of
remember the lie they told and and plus
they're just honest to start with
they're they're they making plenty of
money they was making as much money as i
did
i uh i'll tell you how that um that came
about
i understand that 10 000 people were
killed every year in medellin colombia
and what they were doing they didn't
they didn't have any organization
and uh if one fellow had 10 kilos and he
wanted it shipped to
new york he would tell his friend and
his friend says sure i'll ship it i have
a pilot and i'll ship it up
and then he would look in the newspapers
oh 40 kilos was busted in new jersey
i'm so sorry yours got busted bang bang
he's dead
so here comes jorge ochoa and the
three ochoa brothers and pablo escobar
and gotcho and
they decided that we will make an
insurance company
that we would charge you ten thousand
dollars to take it to your
contact in miami
if it gets lost anywhere between the
time i put it on the airplane
or the time you give it to us and the
time we give it to your man
we will replace it in colombia for you
so there was no way anybody could lose
and i understand they got 100 tons piled
up
under that insurance program and i was
right there the first day
so i had all the work i could do i would
land in this i said when you want me to
come back
we waiting on you senor well let me ask
a difficult question uh some see escobar
as a brutal murderer and some see him as
maybe a robin hood like figure who
helped the poor
how do you see the man both of them i
think he started out to be honest would
help the poor
and then they had a war down there and
they blew up and killed his people
and the country was divided almost
equally three ways
they had the uh the military
they were just as much into it as
anybody and then you had the farc
gorillas
they had about a third of the country
and then you had the contras it was like
the white farmers
and they're the ones that i was dealing
with and they were at war with one
another
and so if one of them started killing
their people i'll kill some of yours too
so that that's how it happened and then
when i heard about pablo escobar
blowing up that airliner and killing
those women and children i was sorry i
ever shook his hand
that's that's brutal murder so you would
say
escobar is not a good man not at all
it's terrible
now looking back on it when i met him he
was good
did just exactly what he said he would
do could he be a bad man
and a man you can trust are those
absolutely you could trust him yes
so from your perspective in terms of
business
he was reliable he was honest had
integrity
you could work with him oh he felt safe
completely
we flew up and uh to his ranch and even
we brought out motorcycles to start with
and can you ride a motorcycle of course
i can ride a motorcycle
so i took off across the grass and there
was a little ditch there
and the front wheel dropped in that
thing and i must have slid across that
grass 20 feet
before i got stopped he almost fell off
his for his
bike waiting because they knew what it
was going to do and then we got on
horses
and went out there and pretended to have
to round up some cows
and he put a mac 10 machine gun pistol
over my shoulder you know how to use
this
well i never had but it was all right i
think it was like
okay you got 10 bodyguards what do you
need me for
so that's the kind of time we laughed
and talked and drove some cows over the
stumps
you